good day my name is dr. Brian rivers
from Morehouse School of Medicine where
I'm on the faculty of community health
and preventive medicine and I also have
a privilege and honor of directing the
cancer health equity Institute our
Cancer Center dedicated to eliminating
cancer disparities and advancing cancer
health equity well it is indeed an honor
and privilege to be before you today
speaking from a topic multi-level
interventions and cancer prevention and
control a community-based translational
research framework to address prostate
cancer disparities just by way of
introduction I've been researching this
topic for the past 15 years across the
cancer continuum and when I say cancer
continuum I meaning from education and
prevention screening early detection to
diagnosis treatment as well as
survivorship although they attempt to
better understand and put interventions
forth to eliminate the disproportionate
burden that we see among African
American men as relates to prostate
cancer
and more recently my work has expanded
to include breast cancer colorectal
cancer and lung cancer but today I'll be
presenting some of the work that we've
been doing funded by the National
Institutes of Health on prostate cancer
disparities research I'm a behavioral
scientist by training with the public
health background I attended vanderbilt
undergrad major know biology minored in
molecular biology and then went on in
completed NPH and Social and Behavioral
Sciences Sciences in mph being master of
Public Health then I went on and
completed my PhD in health behavior at
the University of Alabama at Birmingham
in the School of Public Health main so
again a lot of my work has focused on
community-based intervention development
and implementation and evaluation I'm
utilizing evidence-based models such as
the patient navigation model the the
role of theory as well as
community-based participatory research
all the things that I would touch under
my topic so today the structure for this
talk
we'll start off with overviewing the
problem i've been will go into some
great detail about what is translational
research the framework that nih has put
forth for the scientific community to
utilize as we operationalize this
concept then i want to talk briefly
about the science of community
engagement is so important as it relates
to interfacing with minority communities
and their strategies and approaches or
the approach that we utilize to really
better understand the role of informed
decision making and non clinical
settings and then i will culminate this
presentation with just briefly a brief
discussion on what we have learned and
what should our next steps be and so
according to the American Cancer Society
recent publication cancer facts and
figures we know that prostate cancer is
most commonly diagnosed cancer among men
followed by lung and colon and then as
relates to women or females we know
their births cancer is most commonly
diagnosed cancer among women followed by
among and colon as well and so when we
look at incidence rates or you know
basically detailing how many individuals
would be diagnosed with cancer in the
given time period and we see that Kester
students rates are higher in males and
females for each racial and ethnic
populations represented in this
paragraph so at the bottom of the x-axis
we have not explained the quite not as
spending black Asian Pacific Islander
American Indian and Alaska Native and
then Hispanic and as you can see the
difference in terms of incidence rates
between racial ethnic groups the highest
incidence rates as you would note our in
blacks among males and in whites among
females and so you see that you know
sort of this disparity in terms of race
and ethnicity but you also see the same
disparity or similar to um disparity as
relates to gender of note Asian Pacific
Islanders have the lowest rates among
both sexes there's also important to
know that these are broadly defined
groups within which can
rates vary substantially what do we mean
by that so we see non-hispanic black
realizing that black is not a monolith
it's not a monolithic group and so
there's great cultural diversity and
variation where you know within that
category one could be a Jamaican descent
African descent
Bahamian or other Caribbean descent I'm
similar to Hispanics you know we sort of
lump these individuals together by one
could be from Puerto Rico or Central
America or South America that all fit
into that category of being Hispanic
realizing that there may be some
cultural variation that needs to be
better understood to contextualize their
health outcomes so now when we look in
terms of mortality rates or cancer death
rates we see that cancer death rates are
higher among males than among females
for every racial and ethnic group and
then we also of note is that black males
as well as black females have the
highest cancer mortality in comparison
to any other racial ethnic group and
these are the reasons I you know we've
set out with such a robust agenda as
relates to better understanding the
disproportionate impact of cancer on
minority groups and particularly African
Americans because we know that this
population blacks in general male and
female are suffering in comparison to
you know others and we try to understand
why why is this the case is related to
the biology of the individual is it
related to where one lives work and play
or is it one's behavior the things that
they engage in whether it's physical
activity or their dietary patterns or
smoking behavior or use of alcohol and
other drugs or is it a combination of
factors including the environment that
has to be contextualized to better
understand this just a portion impact
among this group now we know that you
know mortality rates are on the decline
for all racial ethnic groups but the
disparity remains and we're seeing the
extension of survival rates as
illustrated in this particular
on diagram but but again you see when
you do white and black comparisons you
see that you know but I still have a
much much lower survival for many of the
cancers listed and compared to whites
and again the question begs why
so some postulated reasons as I
mentioned previously include genetics
looking at the biological disposition
are there no mutations in the genome
that could account for the
disproportionate impact of cancer on one
population versus another because it
life now is it one's behavior whether we
focus on nutrition or physical activity
or other behaviors that may be a
detriment moving to these adverse health
outcomes among these different racial
ethnic groups we understand access as a
huge factor as well there's been quite a
bit of conversation you know in this
country in terms of who's able access to
health care system and how effectively
I'm they're able to access interface
were there with the healthcare system we
know that the social economic status or
SES which is usually two measures put
together one at being education as well
as income you know we know that those
are factors as well and we know that 24%
of African Americans live below the
federal poverty threshold versus 8% of
white so that in part could dictate you
know the level of access one may have
but there are many recent years programs
at safety safety net type strategies
that have been put forth to try and
overcome access issues and so now we're
looking we have a few studies that are
actually looking at what happens once
they are in the healthcare system only
and then lastly patient provider
communication and again this is just one
example of what goes on in that in the
encounter between a patient and their
provider on the role of health literacy
the role of cultural sensitivity and
appropriateness just to name a few and
also health education and health
promotion you know all these are factors
that we know impact the extent of the
patient provider communication and
that patient then continues along 13:1
or becomes stagnant other contributing
factors as evidence in the current
literature we know that minority
populations specially african-americans
are more likely to be diagnosed at a
later stage again the cultural
historical and social issues that you
know African Americans have as well as
other racial ethnic groups and
encountered through their course in this
country we were better understanding the
role of misconceptions and fears and
attitudes and I think you know the most
prominent one and I had it voted for a
reason because the remainder of this
presentation will focus on what we did
to try and address the low levels of
awareness and knowledge exhaustion times
you know without the information
individuals just don't know what to do
and there's been quite a bit of
confusing information especially around
prostate cancer screening and the role
of informed decision-making of
characterizing the delivery of informed
decision-making no has been very limited
today and so again we have this
population that is just before she
impacted by prostate cancer but then
where the in times past has been mixed
messaging around is should we be
utilizing prostate cancer screening over
always there have been a better
biomarker other than the prostate
specific antigen which is what is
measured via the PSA tests I mean is
that is do we have a better more better
biomarker or you know and if we do how
do we implement that into a routine care
and so there's been a number of
limitations in terms of the studies that
have attempted to answer this question I
merely due to the lack of representation
of high-risk groups and so these studies
are not a role enough after Americans or
and/or those with a family history of
prostate cancer to high risk populations
that we have to do a better job with in
terms of studying and researching than
24th strategies
but we understand I'm also from our
recent effort so there's a broad
variance broad category of factors that
may in fact influence disparities and
prostate cancer more recently but I was
fortunate enough to have been a part of
a work group during my tenure on the
National Advisory Council for the
National Institutes on minority health
and health disparities and as a part of
that work group we put forth new
conceptual model if you will that really
helps in the framing of disparities
looking at all the levels of influence
as well as those domains of influence
that impact health outcomes
now this mom this conceptual model is
best when I read from left to right and
then from top to bottom and as you can
see it's bi-directional in scope so we
should not look at any of these
different boxes in a linear fashion
but realize that there's an interactive
component among these different concepts
and so real quickly going through the
different levels of influence you know
historically I think we've done a great
job and a really better understanding
the individual level of influence or
what we call in our conceptual models a
personal level you know and that entails
individual in terms of their behavior
their personal environment where they
live their cultural identity and then
their level of access to health care but
more recently we we've come to better
understand and appreciate the additional
levels of influence the interpersonal
level which includes one's social
network the community level again where
one live work and play in a societal
level which is inclusive of policy which
is the principal governance structure
for our society and that really dictates
the construction of our communities then
the different domains of influence
whether the influence impacts biological
or the behavioral or the physical and/or
socio-cultural environment or the health
system itself now all these are factors
that we're putting forth as saying you
know you don't have to dress all of them
at one time but give consideration for
whatever you're studying of these
different concepts so these differ
levels of influence and the domains that
they're influencing and then how it
basically dictates to health outcomes so
we're using utilizing that framework and
again it's intended to reflect an array
of factors that are highly relevant for
understanding and addressing minority
health and health disparities what it
encourages England it was approached to
individuals studying this particular
problem is that it's a multi-faceted and
it's multi-level and scope dozen assess
it takes that type of approach as
relates to research it also brings to
attention health outcomes $0.90
individual level by looking more broadly
more globally look at the family looking
at the community in also population
levels and then you know I saw this
business framework is also purpose to
provide classic classification scheme if
you will for assessing the progress the
gaps where they are and then what
opportunities we have to move forward so
it's very comprehensive in scope I'm
excited by it just in terms of allowing
us to advance our understanding of all
of the factors involved and disparate
outcomes among various racial and ethnic
groups as well as between genders what
this framework is not intended to do
though is to display directionality or
specific causal pathways that then can
be interpreted as an explanation for
etiology or you know how disease you
know begins it's not an exhaustive
representation about theories of factors
or mechanisms but I think it captures
you know a gauntlet of of those factors
that we feel and that have been shown in
previous research studies to be of
importance and so that takes us to
utilizing understanding you know the
array of factors that I'm often are
implicated as relates to propagating
disparities and serving as barriers to
the investment of health equity you know
we have this translational science
spectrum you know that a lot of
individuals are now
I'm focused on we've had some great
discoveries we have some great advances
as I mentioned earlier there's a current
decline in mortality among racial and
ethnic groups for most of our cancers
but you know we still have this
disparity that we need to better
understand and so how do we ensure that
those discoveries that are made at the
bench are translated to application and
community-based settings I mean in
clinical settings excuse me but then
ultimately translated to benefit to
populations as well as ultimately to the
policy level is that we utilize you know
a translational science spectrum and
translational research fosters a
multi-directional
integration of basic research patient
oriented research in population-based
research with a long-term aim of
improving the health of the public and
so as we think about the translation to
the community level we need to
conceptualize and understand that there
are multiple types of community
engagement search of principle
importance is what is the community now
I don't depends there's no right or
wrong answer but it all depends on how
you conceptualize what is community is
it a geographical area captured by a zip
code or or or city ordinance or state or
could it be a community of individuals a
community of prostate cancer survivors
or community of black men interested in
eliminating prostate cancer disparities
so again it's very important in terms of
how I conceptualize this community a
common immunity around a particular area
or topic there's different types of
community engage research of course the
most I think widely popular one is a
community-based research and then
practice based research and then there's
also community-based participatory
research which is not a recent concept
although it may mean maybe but this
model has been around for a while
really engaged a community and you
empower the community to be equal
participants in the conduct of research
and we're going to go into greater
detail of subsequent slides so what is
community-based participatory research
well has been defined as a collaborative
approach I think that's a key
collaborative approach to research that
equitably if I had a highlighter I'll
highlight that word equitably involves
all partners in the research process
it recognizes the unique strengths that
each brings so I myself as a researcher
as a commission I will not go into any
community thinking I have all the
answers or I know it needs to happen I
understand what the data says I
understand trends in the data I mean
which suggests a particular approach but
I never say it's final when I go into
the community we finalized the approach
together and I will show for some
strategies that you can put forth and
I'll allow you to help build that trust
to ensure that the approach is
collaborative and as equitable and that
all individuals at the table are sharing
in the power and strengths that they
bring to bring to a particular topic of
problem and so this is just a model of
the cbpr conceptual logic model and then
you know is read from left to right and
it really goes into the different
domains and the importance of
understanding each of those domains and
how those different areas can be
conceptualized for example it starts
with context and what context are you
working within and again this is
important because it helps you frame you
know how you're conceptualizing
community based so that everyone has a
common understanding of what community
is and what you're actually researching
but then it also provides you know
basically the basis for the type of
theory that you're going to use as well
as your the evaluation that you're gonna
utilize to measure
impact and so again various contexts are
listed here goes into great detail in
the boxes what she established a context
then you look at group dynamics when you
start doing a nunchuck partnership
realizing or or detailing who should be
at the table followed by the actual
intervention and the research what
intervention does this population need
and then what it will be the impact of
that intervention and as for the
research come and then what are the
interest painted outcomes and again the
outcomes could span the system's level
I'm all the way to the individual level
again the intra level okay and so you
know this I love this conceptual logic
model because it really helps detail you
know step by step in terms of how one
begins to conceptualize community and
put forth approach for cvpr
and so this is just an example of the
role of the community in the research
process again as you can tell it's not a
linear model but a cyclic meaning that
you know you could team with those you
don't complete a needs assessment and
they move to the identification of
methods but it's a process and the
process is continual you're continuously
evaluating the needs of the community
that you're interfacing with you know
coaching and being to find the best
methodology to put forth with this
particular community given the problem
that you're studying then the design of
the intervention that limitation the
data collection methods analyses
interpretation dissemination of those
study findings which takes you back to
the needs assessment and again is cyclic
it's not a linear process where you do
one thing is sequential than two three
four five six
but those activities are continual and I
think and yes it's labor intensive you
know but that's the epitome that that is
the basis that is why you know
individuals are really looking toward
this process as a sprint to
in research because of the involvement
at the community at every different
stage it never leaves out the community
never reads out the academic but it
brings both together to really better
understand the problem to intervene on
the problem then to evaluate it and then
take that information back out to the
community and so with that as a backdrop
you know everything that I just touched
on from the presenting the
epidemiological data around the problem
as relates to prostate cancer you know
in blacks or african-americans to the
strength of the translational framework
and bringing to bear those in those
strategies to populations that
desperately need them be sure that they
just don't take residence in our
scientific journals but they actually
used to inform next steps and future
policy then also we did a brief overview
over a new conceptual model that the
National Institute of minority health
and health disparities have put forth to
help us conceptualize approaches for
addressing disparities and then lastly
we talked about cbpr so now I want to
bring all these different components
together and so forth what we did to
address issues around prostate cancer
screening among blacks in the stand and
a couple of southern states in the
United States and so as really surprised
that cancer screening you know there's
been quite a bit of controversy around
the two screening modalities one the
prostate specific antigen which is a
blood test measuring the level of PSA
and the prostate specific antigen in the
bloodstream and then the other is the
digital rectal exam or coming for two as
a D re which is basically a certain
finger a gloved finger in the rectum and
checking for any firmness or any
stiffness of the prostate gland you know
that's the standard of care currently in
terms of how we
measure or we screen for prostate cancer
but it's important to note that to date
there's been no randomized clinical
trial showing earlier texts on prostate
cancer by either the d-r-e or the PSA
decreases morbidity or annual mortality
we know that there's issues around false
positive screening tests and what do we
mean by false positive meaning that
there's some screening tests that says
that you have a high level of PSA being
a blood stream or you know you you know
your prostate gland may be enlarged or
may be infected and therefore you get a
positive reading and we know that this
false positive have been denied over
diagnosis men who may not necessarily
benefit from any intervention because it
may not be cancer it could be you know
some other reason why there's a high
amount of PSA in the blood stream and
then we know that these efforts
treatment outcomes for prostate cancer
can lead to very complicated side
effects that diminishes quality of life
for the individual and these include
impotence incontinence strictures
bollinger injury and sometimes death so
what has been put forth as from the
scientific community and the clinical
community for that matter is that
individuals should engage and share
decision-making you know one should take
note of how the patient benefits how the
patient is able to take an active role
in his health care become better
informed and choose the option that is
most consistent with his or his personal
preferences you know these have put
forth I have been put forth as potential
benefits and then how the clinician
benefits you know helps them solve a
particular clinical dilemma
especially around prostate cancer with
high-risk groups such as those with a
family history and or black men because
again we have this disparity before us
for then we have some confusion in terms
of if I show there should not be screen
as an individual as a man first but then
as an individual that may be an
increased risk for prostate cancer
realizing that they were there's really
only three risk factors for prostate
cancer one being african-american a
black the second one having a family
history of this disease and then the
third one as when his age as one gets
older you're more likely to be tonight
diagnosed with prostate cancer so we
know recent reports have pretty much
dictate dictated to us some of the
causal factors and some some of those
mediators and moderators and may be
involved with this disparate impact of
prostate cancer on black men we know
that American men are more likely to
experience poor treatment outcomes as
dictated by this book unequal burden of
cancer we know that african-americans
also more likely to be less satisfied
with treatment outcomes endure greater
symptom distress and have more
persisting urinary bowel a sexual
sentence is ultimately you know
experiencing some family disruption and
then again playing to the notion as I
mentioned earlier we also know that
recent studies have really pointed to
the fact that you know african-americans
are more likely to report having low
access to educational in psychosocial
interventions to really under better
understand the disease and what they
should be doing about the disease we
send a report by this to the medicine
entitled from cancer patient to cancer
survivor I mean really Chronicle for the
first time comprehensively the
psychosocial needs as well as services
that most patients most cancer patients
you know need or expect post treatment
and then also across the continuum what
are some of those information gaps that
can be best addressed to help with
movement across the cancer continuum
realizing that oftentimes if individuals
are fearful which is very resident among
many once they hear the words you have
cancer then as they then become sort of
stagnant or it was stifles
then going on to treatment as well as
other next steps to really freedom from
cancer or cure them from cancer now some
of their information needs as dictated
within this comprehensive report by the
Institute of Medicine included
information about their illness
information about available treatments
some information about other health and
services that may be available to help
them eliminate some of the suffering as
a result of treatment an ancient two
phases of survivorship other
psychosocial needs and services needed
as chronicled in this book included
assistance in coping with emotions
accompanying the illness or treatment
assistance in managing their illness and
then also assistance and making those
lifestyle modifications should they be
needed and these include no changes in
smoking behavior exercising more changes
in diet benefice in with your position
law and really setting up a framework of
surveillance to assist with eliminating
any suffering you know related to this
particular disease and then a couple
years later after the release of 2006
Institute of Medicine report mr. the
medicine came out with a companion
report if you will I'm entitled cancer
care for the whole patient and again it
really talked about you know what the
patient needs and the type of services
that they are in need of and what
strategies we can put forth to really
account for these needs and out of that
came the recommendation as well as the
previous report is that every patient
should have some type of navigational
service available to them to help them
navigate from treatment to survivorship
and to different specialists to
eliminate some of them mid side effects
of treatment and also every patient
should receive some type of summer
summation of what happened to them
we call that a treatment summary already
Chronicle is a type of treatment they
had the type of disease they were
diagnosed which the stage of the disease
a grade of the disease and
selected treatment that was administered
but within also what they can expect as
a transition to survivorship and we call
that as my care plan and so you know
those are two overarching
recommendations that came out which they
felt would help eliminate a lot of the
gaps
may-maybe that we see in them cancer
care and delivery and so with that
information you know we feel it helped
frame our study you know as relates to
really better understanding some of the
information deficits that needed to be
addressed as well as being a be
approached so we utilize a social
ecological model there is similar to
what we saw in the NI MHD framework
looking at multiple levels of influence
realizing that individual is influenced
by their family their friends and their
social networks which are then
influenced by the organization's
organizational cultures and social
institution which is ultimately
influenced by the community in which
these organizations reside in and then
as I mentioned before you know public
policy is that principle governance
structure whether it's national policy
or state and local policy matters in
terms of how one is able to access
health and so what I want to present to
you is a single arm feasibility study
where we received funding through the
National Institute of minority health
and health disparities you know two to
one examine you know the impact of a
multi-level intervention targeting
african-american men who's at increased
risk for prostate cancer we put forward
the multi-level again looking at
thinking back to Anam HD framework and
realizing that there's multiple levels
of influence and there's multiple
domains that we need to account for and
so we put forth a multi-level
community-based educational approach we
utilize community health workers that
we've been trained to work in
community-based settings that
barbershops churches and health fairs we
utilize empirically tested tested and
evaluated patient decision aids and then
we evaluate it from exploratory
standpoint the role of emerging
technology to ensure a standard message
was received by participants given that
this was in a non-political setting and
so these are the components based again
on you know everything that I presented
this far you know based on data based on
national reports then dictated
strategies to help with eliminate the
suffering now we put forth you know I
think a very strong model to deal with
all of those factors and that framework
that could potentially impact the
disparity that we see among African
American men and so the aims of guide of
this study one to evaluate the
effectiveness of the enhanced patient
decision made in title is the psh s
right for you in the delivery of
culturally linguistically and literacy
relevant topics on the informed decision
making to African American men that was
phase one phase two Intel evaluating a
training program for community health
workers to disseminate educational
messages on IBM for prostate cancer
screening to african-american men
utilize the Memphis grounded in
community-based participatory research
and then lastly we set out to compare
the effectiveness of a community-based
education program guided by community
health workers and an enhanced patient
decision aid with usual care in clinical
settings and the dissemination of
informed decision making Chapman air can
men and again you know this is really
important because while the
recommendation has been forth that all
men should engage in the shared
decision-making process and men should
make an informed decision as relates to
if screening is right for them based on
previous studies and I showed this in
previous slides african-americans are
more likely to state they have low
levels of awareness and knowledge about
prostate cancer so how can they then
effectively engage in a shared
decision-making
the conversation will be this sort of
unidirectional and then again the
utilization of community health workers
which is an it or is an iteration of the
patient application model you know again
deals with the contents so those beyond
the individual make deals with the
context or the community in which the
individual resides and so we're not only
impacting the psyche with the education
and the information that the patient
decision relay delivers but then we're
also dealing with the context in which
the individual decides so the community
health worker could help them with
access to care access to screening to
better understand understanding why if
screaming is right for them or if there
was anything that needed clarifying in
the patient decision aid that community
health worker was trained to be able to
provide a system that regard and so
again this model we think you know as a
potential to address not just
individuals knowledge attitudes and
beliefs but also the context which we
know and we better understand that which
is very important and so here's a
multi-level framework it was guided by
the interdependence model of social
influence and interpersonal
communication again really attending to
how we communicate and those influences
at center and community levels and how
they influence ultimately health
outcomes so we took into consideration
social norms the relationship
characteristics the larger system that
individuals operate in as well as the
socio demographic factors realizing that
all of these are factors that impact
communication then we looked at the
agents of social influence and art this
case of community health worker or the
layout advisor and in the targets or the
recipients of of these services
african-americans know intimately the
outcome was were they in a place to
engage in informed decision-making and
what were their behavioral intentions
around screening were they ready to be
screen or they want to wait and receive
more information to determine the spring
was right for them neither study he'll
reveal three sequential phases or
actually phase one and two are
concurrent and then phase three
follow-up phases one and two phase one
we put the patient decision aid you know
before the target audience we wanted to
go through formative research techniques
to ensure that the the patient decision
aid or the intervention that we wanted
to utilize you know increased
information to increase knowledge to
increase awareness resonated culturally
and then go strictly with the population
and so we assessed that door phase one
and they've got currently during phase
two we actually recruited and trained
and evaluated our community health
workers and then phase 3 was the actual
implementation of the study and so just
move on to a little bit more detail of
each of the different phases so again as
a reminder aim one was to evaluate the
effectiveness of the enhanced patient
decision aid and the delivery of
culturally a
mystically and literacy relevant topics
on the form decision-making to
african-american men and so what did we
do we wanted to learn and form the
cultural adaptation or assess if
cultural adapting the patient decision
angles needed we wanted to conduct
pretest iterations or the enhanced
decision aid or then the consult with
medical and technological experts or in
those modifications that we made and so
how do we do this what we do this
through the use of qualitative research
methods focus groups pretest and
iterations which until key informant
interviews or face-to-face interviews
with the target audience and they learn
a free learner verification techniques
which entails a process of performing
adaptations to a particular intervention
and then putting them back before the
target on its or at least representation
of the audience that you're looking to
intervene with to see if the changes
that were made resident
you know with you know with a population
of study and so this was phasing why now
formative research techniques we
interface with my 18 black men their
average age is about 48 and again this
took place and in in Florida and so you
see the breakdown there in terms of the
representativeness of individuals from
st. Pete as well as Tampa most of them
dividuals reported being married is some
type of education mostly most we are
there at the high school and/or some
college level and only about nearly 40%
reported they previously screened for
prostate cancer so some of the key
things that are that emerged on phase
one in ascertaining if we need to adapt
the patient decision aid and in fact we
actually had to the participants wanted
more information related to sources of
health information what are some
credible sources we have this great
wonderful internet before is that you
know has a wide breadth of information
but a lot of participants wanted to know
how do you determine credible reliable
information there's a lot only about
prostate cancer is long there about
prostate cancer screening but how do we
know what is the most credible
information as we do not have a ranking
of our health websites could be one
person share their opinion sharing their
experience versus a an expert really
detailing what the data states or you
know the most recent research finding
state I mean so there's there's quite a
bit of confusion in terms of you know
what is the credible source of
information so we cleared that up
trustworthiness was also a key thing
that emerged how can I trust this
information when Elena's from the
participants quoted as saying that the
information see little changes every six
eight months in may our society you know
the role of mammograms there's been
quite a bit of confusion around you know
the utility of mammograms and the
frequency of mammograms as well and this
information in the community body share
this information in the setting as more
trusted where individuals can involve
their social network and receiving this
information without to help them decide
what's best for them also detailing some
of the important issues about prostate
cancer why is there disparity you know
uh you know what is our current
knowledge about prostate cancer
questioning the context of this
persistent disparity and what are some
of the factors associated with the
disparity and you just wanted to hear
more of a dialogue and conversation not
on those lines and then some of the
barriers of benefits to prostate cancer
screening if there's any cultural issues
they need to be addressed you should
address those as well and then what is
informed decision-making and how is it
measured these are all the key things
that emerged from my formative research
so we cannot take something that you
know work for one group and then apply
it to another group thinking we're gonna
have the same outcomes but we put it
before the representative number of
individuals from our anticipated target
audience to ensure or to evaluate with
this intervention resonate with you are
there things that are missing that
should be included in this particular
intervention and in fact we found that
they wore as only this the next couple
slides are just how we address the
issues you know as relates to sources of
health information you know we we
attempted to include perspectives from
each of those you know sources listed on
your screen from the volition and a
health care provider they attempted to
identify you know sound websites and
individuals can go to to receive
credible health information salient
information and then we included
information for their social network
including friends and peers as well as
their family members in just a little
bit more detail on the trustworthiness
of the information participants though
that the information should come from a
person who's trusted to do to their
relationship for example a wife a friend
or family lover more based on their
skills or training such as the doctor
yes again showing his showing
receptivity of information however there
were some mixed results regarding
trusting doctors some of the
participants some stated that with their
advanced studies in training doctors
should know what they're talking about
but others stated that you still have to
double-check the information as today's
medicine is yesterday's research and
information changes quite frequently and
so it was sort of a mix and we attempted
to address this by including both
perspectives from both thoughts then as
relates our knowledge about problem
about prostate cancer although most of
the participants have heard of prostate
cancer there if you had any knowledge of
prostate cancer some had heard about
screening and treatment but do not know
much about what this meant or included
and some knew that prostate cancer was
more prevalent among black men and older
men but again the reasons as to why was
unclear cultural issues social cultural
norms and beliefs they felt should be
addressed as relates to black men so
that this sort of problem is one size
for the whole approach but we should do
a good deal on this to make sure that
the patient decision aid really speaks
to those issues that are germane to
African Americans and some of these
included that going to the doctor this
notion of homophobia associated with the
digital rectal exam are there
misconceptions and fears that that are
resident among African Americans
reflects the cultural relevance and
understanding of those who are actually
doing the speaking should be taken into
consideration so basically someone who
look like they're more or from their
respective communities who you know
we're trusted individuals they felt was
the best model to put forth then as
relates to inform decision-making many
participants agreed that they needed to
make their own decision regarding
screening due to their lifestyle as well
as other personal factors and that level
of variation for person person there was
some concern about the uncertainty of
outcomes such as positive light and is
often associated with prostate cancer
treatment
as well as the costs and then
recommendation from their family members
to be involved resonated loud and clear
within their formative research and
again pointed to the fact that
individuals at least African American
diets don't make decisions in isolation
but you know involve their social
network or go back to our social ecology
model or even the hilum HD framework
that interpersonal level so it's
extremely important that you know for
that we put in place
you know sources of information for
these individuals as well to facilitate
the decision-making process and other
recommendations that emerge included
many doctors you know if you include
them in a patient decision ancient vary
in age from young and old there should
be some supplemental tools on the
internet such as blogging and websites
television ads and mail outs to complain
to katene to convey that information
because right back then it was just fall
in the clinical setting and oftentimes
that clinical encounter was limited to
seven to ten minutes so there was a much
time for health education health
promotion activities for more so
surveillance and diagnosis men also
suggested maybe having two separate
patient decision aids one completely
with the pros and one completely with
the cons to help sort out the issue
issues and help me make a decision
and then lastly they thought that the
video should be tailored or targeted to
older men but then also to younger men
and their wives and families given that
you know younger men may have um younger
kids and fertility preservation among
other things may be of consideration in
their decision-making process that may
not be factors for older men
so in Phase two we set out to train our
community health workers the community
health worker just from a historical
context is the model that was developed
by the federal government in the 1960s
with the goal of reaching people
underserved communities and presenting
health as well as screening information
so it's mono has been around for over 50
years the philosophy of this model is to
trained selected community members in
specific health topics so that they may
then serve as an educational resource to
other community members in making the
appropriate health decisions a common
limitation to implementing this in
implementing this model but then a
community-based participatory strategy
is a lack of evaluation of assessing the
accuracy as well as the
comprehensiveness of the information in
education that's often provided by these
individuals so utilization of mobile
health could potentially serve as as a
method for standardizing that which is
communicated to impacted communities but
again it remains unknown if dark
americanman are receptive to utilizing
mobile tablet technology to receive
healthy to health education and health
promotion messaging and so again to
summarize this particular slide we knew
that the community health worker model
was great for really interfacing in
different aspects of the community while
there's the barber shop whether it's a
church whether it's different gatherings
in the park or the laundromat or just
going where community members go we knew
that that model was great but then the
question was we have this fantastic
decision date that we just adapted what
is the best method of delivery well we
thought you know we could do paper we
can do brochures but how about doing
something interactive how about doing
something that ensures that the message
is salient and relevant to the target
audience so we decided to utilize mobile
tablet mobile tablet technology and we
call this the mobile health intervention
my soul it helped us with the dome
dilemma of ensuring that a standardized
message was provided to the community
members and then it's a felon is off of
the community health worker to better
understand all the nuances associated
with the recommendations around prostate
cancer screening and so within a
training we train them on utilizing
you know the iPad we had a module on
technology integration the use of the
iPad and delivering information we
gained a community based settings other
training topics included the basics of
prostate cancer and then screening
prostate cancer screening benefits rinse
limitations alternatives as well as
uncertainties and all this was presented
within the framework the Freer's
empowerment or education model and the
cbpr framework and some of the training
methods some evaluation metrics included
different questionnaires we employed a
one group pre post-test design meaning
we did a survey at the beginning of the
training and then we did a survey the
end of the training to evaluate the
impact of the training some of the
sample questions from that survey
including what is a community health
worker the constructive role delineation
what are the core competencies of this
model what are some of the qualities of
the community health workers that helped
them end up their work and how we
demonstrate effective communication
strategies so phase three was the actual
implementation of the patient decision
aid as well as a community health worker
model in community-based settings and
again the patient decision a was
delivered via mobile tablet technology
and so a similar design was assumed
today they valuate the impact of this
multi-level intervention we captured the
graphic variables a primary outcome of
interest was captured at baseline and to
post intervention and our primary
outcomes of interest was IDM and I
inform decision-making and it was
conceptualized through three different
constructs
prostate cancer knowledge decisional
conflict as well as decision on
self-efficacy this is just an overview
started off with the community health
worker I didn't find eligible
participants again whether in a barber
shop
a beautiful church or some type of
community
right an overview of the study and a
bita that you participate
dr. an informed consent followed by the
baseline a pre survey we deliver the
intervention over a course actually this
I think was one week and then we
conducted a post survey then we had to
follow up to ascertain what their
intentions were as relates to prostate
cancer screening and with that for their
participation
we provided relation the amount of the
$20 gift card so these are the results
and as you can see we have some
significant changes as relates to
changes and knowledge self-efficacy as
well as decision conflict we recruited
152 african-american men into the study
we look more specifically as relates to
prostate cancer knowledge you know we
see that this work has been published in
the Journal of health care from the poor
and underserved we see that the changes
in knowledge based on education income
and marital status and age we saw more
change around those who are college
educated when an income greater
forty-eight thousand or more were
married and were over the age of 60 but
look you look at the difference in the
mean in the mean scores even for those
individuals that had less than a college
education or made less than 48 thousand
year or unmarried we still saw decreases
in their scores meaning the impact of
the intervention impacted their those
domains as well regardless of their
education income marital status or age
may be an impact to their prostate
cancer knowledge overall and so that's
important to note there was a
significant amount that group was 15
with the other group who dis he changes
across the board same thing with
prostate cancers training self efficacy
one's ability to engage in screening we
saw that there was so much significance
again
those of the college education those who
made at least forty eight thousand more
those who are married and again those
who were sixty plus years of age then
the last construct sorry decisional
conflict you know we saw significant
changes as well and on the same group
and so data from the two-week funnel of
interviews really so forth there was an
increase and individuals who intended to
go and be screened for prostate cancer
and then after this study we also stayed
down with the community health workers
and conducted interviews basically
capture their extent of the interaction
between the participant and the
community health workers and and again
really identifying it this model should
be put forth and go further again just
some of the data that you know is
captured reacts um a lot of breeches a
lot of the participants to we post the
intervention since the discussion with
the community health worker who have you
spoken with who have you shared this
knowledge of it and mostly say their
social network whether it was a family
member and or friend and so we see that
this sharing of information within their
social network to help them in their
decision making was congruent with
previous studies that talked about the
importance of the interpersonal level
and so you know going forward we would
make an appointment we know we published
this into the scenario you know in our
manuscript related to this particular
study now we can't negate the importance
of the social network so when we're
building out our interventions I should
not just focus on the individual or the
patient themselves but consider those
individuals that are around the patient
or the participant and proceed
accordingly so the results of this study
prostate cancer after interacting with
the community health worker ninety-five
percent felt that the community health
worker was knowledgeable
an incredible source of information
again checking to this notion or the
theme that emerged in the formative
research related to the patient decision
aid no credible sources of information
and then over 50% of a participant
stated that they actually spoke with a
family member or a friend after their
interaction of the community health
worker about prostate cancer so in
attending to the role of the
interpersonal you know level and how one
should intervene on that level in
addition to the intra or the individual
level and so real quickly as it relates
to our evaluation of the technology now
you hear some of the individuals say
well the technology exasperate
disparities where they put a wedge in
between minority populations and others
and so we set out to evaluate the
usability of you know this program our
intervention or the use of mobile tablet
technology so what is these ability
basically the extent to which a product
can be used by specified users to
achieve specified those but the
effectiveness efficiency and
satisfaction in a specified context of
use usability is usually measured or
evaluated by user driven or expert
driven approaches and so we took forth
the user driven approach to evaluate the
use or the delivery of our patient
decision aid he and I had these are just
some examples of the questions that we
put forth and then we did a usability
evaluation of the actual patient
decision aid itself and again these are
just some of the questions that was put
forth an evaluation of that so we have
53 participants mean age is about 41
years the Rangel's between 18 and 69
years old and about 2029 were male and
so as you can see the
for education event comes represented by
the pie charts majority of reporting and
income of twenty to sixty thousand and
the majority report is entitled
vocational school or some college again
these are the measurements that when
youth that we utilize to aspects that we
measured general ease-of-use mainly of
the iPad itself and then studied
specific these abuse mainly the patient
decision aid or at the top in which we
deliver the patient decision made to
participants its overall though
individuals felt that it was very easy
to use as represented though then in the
blue green bar and then there's any
specific ease-of-use
was likewise very well received in
visuals did not report any challenges
were utilizing this particular modality
to receive information we conducted our
one way ANOVA is looking at if education
level was a factor and we found that
participants educational levels did not
have any significant effect or their
assessment on general ease of use or
study of specific needs abuse the Levent
role of income again you know we saw
this differential impact in an
intervention as relates to education and
income so we wanted to see if there was
any what was the role of Education and
or income as relates to the receipt of
technology or the use of technology for
health LT can be a behaviors and again
participants income levels did not have
any sums that can't effect on their
assessment of ease of use and studies
specific ease of use and so in
conclusion the increasing complexity of
information or the prostate cancer
continuum challenges patients and
acquiring adequate resources for the
information aids the use of technology
we think will ensure the delivery of a
consistent in educational of a
consistent educational content thereby
reducing the
information variation often associated
with community-based education
multi-level interventions we found
what's feasible to implement using a
cvpr framework we also found that it was
feasible to Train community health
workers to deliver a mobile tablet
delivery intervention over all the
participants found the patient decision
aids be easy to use neither their
education level or income level at any
significant effect on the evaluation of
the patient decision made this is
important because as you can see you
know we was trying to see a spike in the
incidence of metastatic prostate cancer
among men and we don't know study has
not been doctored to detail
if this spike in advanced stage disease
is the hen result of the confusion
around the recommendations for prostate
cancer training or you have a group that
decided not to be screened well some
just sort of waited in the middle oh and
then some of course went on a gas stream
but you know this is a disease when
found early is 100% treatable once it
becomes stage 3 and stage 4 or
metastatic you know that's when it
causes a lot of problems in the cure
rate those from you know 90 to the ninth
from the 90th percentile down to the
30th or 40th percentile and and so is
incoming that we get the messaging out
as we realize that there is an uptake of
advanced stage disease in the inner
disease that when found early enough is
definitely treatable then visuals I live
and beyond the 10-year survival are so
final thoughts now having a Community
Advisory Board consisting of community
members health care providers research
researchers academics students involved
in identification of selection of
community health workers was extremely
important and beneficial our community
health worker training program was based
on adult learning principles and utilize
didactic group role-playing and actual
field work to enhance critical thinking
and problem-solving skills among
community health
workers we found that multi-method
monitoring and evaluation to assess
knowledge change of retention as well as
performance was extremely beneficial joy
operationalizing the community health
worker model I think it was extremely
important that we did not just utilize
it as patient decision aid that had been
used with other populations but the the
incorporating community perspectives
helped define and identify a range of
research options and provided a
foundation for working with community
partners to develop community-based
translational research in bringing nor
the most recent a salient findings to
communities and our this fortunately
impacted by you know disease that can
really stand to benefit from these
advances the community based Theory
approach identified community relevant
and research questions and Memphis to
address current gaps in our
understanding of prostate cancer
disparities across the continuum and the
process now comes the mystery how
community perspectives and scientific
theory can inform the development of
translational research addressing
prostate cancer disparities across
various levels of influence in our study
we found that the community members are
actively engaged in the study which
helped build trust with academic
institutions also the label the
community health workers know to possess
health-related knowledge communication
skills and leadership experience that
will extend along beyond the study and
we again I'm left the iPad stand with
the community health workers and and key
community settings as well cbpr and
tandem with community health workers is
a valuable approach for engaging
african-american men and is able to
attenuate not only to establishing trust
but also addressing those cultural
factors that we know are important you
know model minority populations
involvement of multi levels such as the
community members organizations academic
institutions house
community health care providers aided in
acceptance and sustainability of the
intervention so again you know it was
important in terms of how we
conceptualize this intervention and the
inclusion of multiple domains of
insurance as well as multiple levels of
influence and so future approaches
nestled within the DNI framework for the
invitation of dissemination science
framework we would definitely foster an
advocate for the utilization of
community health workers on that model
is an immense value and that's very
promised and how we translate our
findings to the benefit of different
communities potential application in the
context of increasing readiness of
populations minority populations to
engage in a community-based biospecimen
collection as we know diversification
and many of our clinical trials as well
as our research studies remain a problem
and the community health worker could be
one strategy to address that issue
because about that level of
diversification how do we know drug
discovery will be beneficial for all
individuals and so we've seen we've seen
an increase in the number of individuals
in the context of cancer that our
failing treatment or our treatment is
failing them we need that better
representation so as these new drug
targets are develop we can ensure that
their representative and generalizable
job individuals and then community based
education via technology I think
resonates very well in terms moving
forward in terms of leveraging
technology to help standardize the
messaging and the approach within
community-based settings well there was
the same level of credibility that one
receives or has receiving information in
clinical settings and so again this is
an example you know the how terms of how
do we get this type of work done
mechanimal ours for the medicine we are
committed to leading the creation and
advancement of health equity by bringing
research to the community and this is
just one example through our mobile
research
as equipped focus groups conduct surveys
they even took clay bomb different
biospecimens and and so you know as we
transform the landscape to really go to
the people as opposed to waiting for
individuals to come to us we really are
confident that these approaches will
help us advance health equity and
decrease the disparities that we see I
like to thank you for your time and
attention this is today you know of
course I like to acknowledge our funding
our sponsor the National Institute on
minority health and health disparities
this is funding under their comparative
effectiveness research eliminating
disparities initiative and it was closer
to me dollar investment to implement his
ta project so we're very fortunate for
the resources that were provided by NIH
and I am HD again thank you and feel
free to contact me if you have any
questions I think my contact information
is listed with this presentation I can
be contacted via B rivers B as a boy
rivers are IBD RS at MSM that edu that's
Morehouse School of Medicine that he be
MSM and I look forward to hearing from
you I hope you enjoy the presentation
and have a great day